la commande publique du département de
la réunion
[Musique]
comment accéder aux marchés publics
départementaux c'est simple pour les
montants inférieurs à 40 mille euros
faites vous connaître à cette adresse
marchés publics @ cg974 point fr les
marchés dans le montant est supérieur à
40 mille euros sont accessibles dans les
journaux locaux plus gérer le quotidien
ou sur internet sur marchés publics
point cg974 point fr vous avez la
possibilité d'être alertés du lancement
d'un marché vous concernant de consulter
des avis de télécharger des dossiers de
marchés publics de remettre des offres
de manière dématérialisée
d'interroger les services départementaux
la dématérialisation est obligatoire
depuis le 1er octobre 2018 une
consultation étape par étape étape un
appel à candidatures
étape 2 consultation de l'appel par les
entreprises
étape 3 soumission des entreprises
étape 4 réception des candidatures
étape 5 examen et attributions
la dématérialisation en six questions
pourquoi et comment s'inscrire sur à w s
fournisseurs cette inscription vous
permet d'obtenir des codes d'accès afin
de télécharger les des ce2 correspond
avec des acheteurs et de déposer vos
offres par voie dématérialisée
vous pouvez choisir d'être alerté par
courriel sur les appels d'offres qui
vous correspondent pour bien paramétrer
votre profil de veille consultez le mode
d'emploi en ligne sur votre espace
fournisseurs dans la rubrique outils
tutoriel comment retirer un dossier de
consultation des entreprises
les règlements de consultations et les
décès sont téléchargeables gratuitement
les fournisseurs inscrits sont
automatiquement informés des changements
apportés au dossier télécharger en cours
de procédure comment poser vos questions
et suivre vos réponses les questions
posées par le canal correspondent avec
l'acheteur nous sont directement
transmises et vous pouvez retrouver vos
messages et les réponses sur votre
espace fournisseurs comment signer vos
documents la signature n'est plus
obligatoire mais reste autorisée un mode
d'emploi en ligne est à votre
disposition
comment déposer un pli dématérialiser le
dépôt dématérialisée a été simplifié au
maximum pour vous mais n'attendez pas la
dernière minute vous rencontrez un souci
technique l'assistance technique est
joignable par téléphone au 04 81 04 12
60 ou en ligne support tirer entreprises
@ à w est tirée france.com
répondre aux marchés du département
c'est simple une procédure favorable aux
entreprises un avis d'appel public à la
concurrence un délai de remise des plis
une remise des plis l'analyse des offres
120 jours maximum sur la base de
documents simplifiée classement des
offres analyse des candidatures seul le
candidat pressenti pour être tributaire
fourni toutes les pièces relatives la
candidature et aux marchés admission de
la candidature et notification du marché
un acte de candidature simplifier les
seuls éléments que le candidat doit
renseigner sont les nom prénoms siret et
coordonner les principes généraux le
département simplifie l'acte de
candidature à ces marchés publics pas de
formalisme excessif le nombre de pièces
exigées et limiter une information n'est
demandé qu'une fois pour l'offre les
pièces relatives à l'offre réduites à
leur plus simple expression un seul
document financier est exigée les
risques d'erreurs de calcul et de report
sont limitées
un cadre de mémoire technique pour
guider les candidats dans la
constitution de leurs offres techniques
un cadre de mémoire technique est
insérée dans les décès il indique les
rubriques que doit comprendre le mémoire
technique à la remise des plis aucune
signature n'est requise
pour l'attribution seul le candidat
pressenti pour devenir attributaire du
marché nous fournir toutes les pièces
exigées et les signer pour les candidats
les attestations fiscales et sociales
prouvant qu'il est en règle les
documents attestant de ses niveaux de
capacité pour l'offre il remettra toutes
les pièces de l'offre signé
remporté les marchés du département vous
avez toutes vos chances pour faciliter
et ouvrir largement l'accès à sa
commande publique le département affine
ses différents lots au sein de ces
marchés ils nous sont faits à la fois
sur la base technique et géographique
exemple marché des transports des élèves
handicapés 92 lots travaux de
maintenance des bâtiments départementaux
48 lots travaux de réhabilitation des
collèges 16 lots services de géométrie
et bornage huile ou formations en
bureautique d'îlots
il limite systématiquement le nombre de
lots pouvant être attribuée à une même
entreprise il attribue les marchés selon
plusieurs critères la valeur technique
l'environnement la qualité le prix n'est
pas le seul critère de jugement de
l'offre il détecte systématiquement les
offres anormalement basses et les
élimine le cas échéant entre janvier et
septembre 2021 21h détectée est rejetée
il propose aux entreprises un régime d'
avance majoré
l'amélioration des conditions de
paiement depuis 2010 9,1 régime d'
avance favorable aux entreprises un toad
avance de 30 % pour tous les marchés
avec une partie sans garantie pouvant
atteindre soixante mille euros
une diminution des retenue de garantie
le taux applicable passe 2 5% à 3% un
engagement pour un paiement rapide
depuis 2019 le département s'engage
seront délais de paiement de 25 jours